when we first learned algebra together
we started factoring polynomials
especially quadratics we recognized that
an expression like x squared could be
written as x times x we also recognized
that a polynomial like 3x squared plus
4x that in this situation both terms had
the common factor of x and you could
factor that out and so you could rewrite
this as x times
three x plus four
and we also learned to do fancier things
we learned to factor things like x
squared plus seven x plus twelve we were
able to say hey what two numbers would
add up to seven and if i were to
multiply them i get 12 and in those
early videos we show why that works and
say well three and four so maybe this
can be factored as x plus three
times
x
plus four if this is unfamiliar to you i
encourage you to go review that in some
of the introductory factoring quadratics
on khan academy it should be review at
the at this point in in your journey we
also looked at things like differences
of squares
x squared minus 9. say hey that's x
squared minus 3 squared so we could
factor that as x plus 3 times x minus 3.
we looked at other types of quadratics
now as we go deeper into our algebra
journeys we're going to build on this to
factor higher degree polynomials third
degree fourth degree fifth degree which
will be very useful in your mathematical
careers
but we're going to start doing it by
really looking at some of the structure
some of the patterns that we've seen in
introductory algebra for example let's
say someone walks up to you on the
street and says can you factor x to the
third plus 7x squared plus 12 x
well at first you say oh this is a third
degree polynomial that seems kind of
intimidating until you realize hey all
of these terms have the common factor x
so if i factor that out then it becomes
x times x squared plus 7x plus 12. and
then this is exactly what we saw over
here so we could rewrite all of this as
x times
x plus 3 times x plus 4. so we're going
to see that we might be able to do some
simple factoring like this and even
factoring multiple times we might also
start to appreciate structure that
brings us back to some of what we saw in
our introductory algebra so for example
you might see something like this where
once again someone walks up to you on
the street and says hey you factor this
a to the fourth power plus seven a
squared plus twelve and at first you're
like wow there's a there's a fourth
power here what do i do
until you say well
what if i were to rewrite this as
a squared squared
plus 7
a squared
plus 12. and now this a squared is
looking an awful lot like this x over
here if this were an x
then this would be x squared if this
were an x then this would just be an x
and then these expressions would be the
same so when i factor it everywhere i
see an x i could replace with an a
squared
so i could factor this out really
looking at the same structure we have
here as a squared plus 3
times a squared plus 4. now i'm going
really fast for this this is really the
introductory video the overview video
don't worry if this is a little bit much
too fast this is really just to give you
a sense of things later in this unit
we're going to dig deeper into each of
these cases
but just to give you a sense of where
we're going i'll give you another
example that builds off of what you
likely saw in your introductory algebra
learning
so building off of the structure here if
someone were to walk up to you again a
lot of people are walking up to you
and say factor
4 x to the 6th
minus 9 y to the 4th well first this
looks quite intimidating until you
realize that hey i could write both of
these as squares i could write
this first one as
2x to the third squared
minus and i could write this second term
as 3y squared squared and now this is
just a difference of squares this would
be 2x
to the third
plus 3 y squared
times 2x to the third minus 3 y squared
we'll also see things like this where
we're going to be factoring multiple
times so once again someone walks up to
you in the street and they say you're a
very popular person someone walks up
just stays up to you on the street and
says factor x to the fourth minus y to
the fourth
well based on what we just saw you could
realize that this is the same thing as x
squared squared
minus y squared squared and you say okay
this is a difference of squares just
like this was a difference of squares so
it's going to be
the sum of x squared and y squared x
squared plus y squared times the
difference of them x squared minus y
squared now this is fun because this is
2 a difference of squares so we can
rewrite this whole thing as i'll rewrite
this first part
x squared
x squared plus y squared and then we
could factor this as a difference of
squares just as we factored this up here
and we get x plus y
times x minus y so i'll leave you there
i've just bombarded you with a bunch of
information but this is really just to
get you warmed up don't stress about it
because we're going to go deep into each
of these and there's going to be plenty
of chances to practice it on khan
academy to make sure you understand
where all of this is coming from
enjoy